the Joe Rogan experience is that really
good strategy to be lifting these guys
over the steep a when steep a fought
Francis and Ghana oh that was yes I
managed to avoid the big actions of in
Ghana and then wear him out and take
beat up and retain the title the only
guy that's been able to survive in Ghana
the DC fight is a hard one to watch man
cuz he's the best guy in the world he's
so nice I love that guy to death so
watching him get his body destroyed
because he kept digging those left hooks
in the body I was like woo part of me
was like damn that's a pretty pile out
were those [ __ ] loud but it's it's it
wasn't it was the crispness of it he was
he was standing in front of on top of
them and then slide in back and he would
just stick that [ __ ] the left hook
into the deliver and he is kept hitting
it part of me was like man that is a
beautiful left hook
nasty body shots but part of me is like
damn DC you got to get away from that
you got to get out of there you got to
take this guy down it's hard when you're
when you really love a guy and you watch
them fight it's hard it's very very
difficult to do commentary you just
what's the pain on that on the liver
punches what could that always what's
the damage that can do this shoes that
makes you like I've seen people crumble
or show me a little don't want it it
it's a horrible feeling wear it like
like shocks your body let me say Johnny
goes like it's or show how about the
show gave wording right here it's right
there I was getting shocked lower if you
if if someone is standing in front of
you and you they hit you with a left
hook most likely they'd be hitting you
in the liver and it's like right where
these floating ribs are tucked and when
you slam someone hard like right around
the look you know some one of the
Masters of it is Canelo Alvarez say show
Canelo Alvarez body shots like maybe
there's a video we could look he's got a
beautiful one we steps in it just
[ __ ] rips that left hook to the liver
and just your body just goes deep it's
the weirdest feeling man it's like your
legs stop working everything stops
working your whole body
[Music]
it looks like it didn't happen to him
until that last one I think he was
playing poker face I think he was
playing poker face the Canelo's a
[ __ ] master at this [ __ ] he would
just dig this thing look at this that
one's going to the side but most the
time he's going to the liver most the
time well he's going to anything that's
open right that's the liver she's going
for the liver against golovkin but
golovkin got that lower that low guard
with his right arm he's blocking it from
happening the guy was coming up next
talking so it's so it's so much fun like
it's a fun sword to do well when these
kind of guys are fighting when triple G
and Canelo are fighting like [ __ ] it's
like if you're a fan of the sport you've
seen the highest level two champions in
their prime going after it it's it's
amazing to watch
but that punches a ted-like and getting
hit there's a terrible feeling and DC
got hit there multiple times and he was
from like the second round on he was at
you were talking about it when he's
there but he was just putting his hands
down and kind of lesson steep a hit on
his heart that's a dangerous way to
fight ste paimio judge like I think he
just wanted to put pressure on him and
make steep a feel like he didn't deserve
to be in there with him I think maybe in
that approach he was trying to wear him
out which keep the pressure on him and
make him discouraged or maybe he had
genuine disdain for his abilities maybe
he really didn't think too steep it
could hurt him and he's just eventually
gonna catch him and then there was a lot
of people that thought because of the
way he knocks D pay out maybe ste pays
and his durable is used to be right
because steep a used to take tremendous
shots from everybody but then he got
knocked out with one punch by DC after
taking tremendous shots in the in Ghana
fight so the question would be like how
much damage is he taking that in Ghana
fight but then he came back and he ate
everything that DC had to offer him he
just kept beating and the kid take it on
the chin and eating it and eventually he
started taking over the fight and when
he started ripping the body in the
fourth round it was like whoa he it was
perfect I mean I've never seen anybody
have better body punches in a
championship what was that was think
there was like a corner call or you
think he just like improvised and saw
that that was open and he knows how to
fight yeah I saw an opening everybody
everybody know I mean that's such a
standard technique that's like a corner
call someone's throwing a leg kick it
social organs I was working Susan
yeah it never got blocked once he didn't
have an answer he didn't have an answer
to it he didn't duck it he didn't block
it he didn't he didn't try to take him
down he just kind of got stuck Stan the
problem with those liver shots too is
they SAP your energy so bad and you you
can't make a big move anymore so you
have to kind of pretend like
everything's okay and then BAM he hits
you again you're like oh [ __ ] we're in
trouble here but still you're looking
like nothing's wrong but your gas tank
is [ __ ]
everything's on empty and you're [ __ ]
you really can't fire back that's why DC
didn't fire back and he kept getting
shot to that body bang and every time
bang he gets shot to that body you see
this and then Steve pate got him against
the cage started uncorking punches and
DC just didn't have anything to his body
was shutting down didn't have anything
in him to stop that onslaught means
amazing that guys to this steep a is the
most successful heavyweight in the
history this merit
[Applause]